it has been a sweltering summer in
madrid
but as temperatures have soared so too
has the cost of fuel
so the spanish government has mandated
that offices and stores cannot set their
cooling systems below 27 degrees celsius
in an area dependent on tourism locals
are afraid the heat wave and crackdown
on energy could scare visitors away
it's going to be impossible because now
we're at 18 degrees inside if we go up
to 27 degrees we're going to be sweating
all day we won't need to go to the gym
the fridges give out a lot of heat and
the customers are going to complain
nobody's going to come in
but the spanish government has already
agreed with the other european union
countries to cut dependency on russian
gas by 15
by the end of the year
we have to comply with the agreements we
have reached in brussels
spain also has a commitment of
solidarity with the rest of european
countries
each country is free to choose the way
in which it will meet the commitment to
cut energy use here in spain that
includes turning off the lights
perhaps other measures need to be found
because i don't know up to what point
turning off a shop window display light
is going to make much saving
shops have to turn off window lights
after 10 pm however street lighting will
not be affected
why would visitors come because when you
go out for a walk what you want to see
is joy but soon we won't have lights so
if you decide to come to here and
everything is switched off you're going
to ask yourself what's the point
the measures will be reversed in winter
when regulations will prohibit indoor
areas not to be warmed above 27 degrees
lea harding al jazeera